mes chers amis mes chers collègues le
Conseil économique social et
environnemental c'est eux adoptés le 11
avril dernier un avis sur la gestion
durable de l'eau en France face au
changement climatique dans le cadre de
la mission d'information sur l'eau
lancer en février au Sénat nous recevons
aujourd'hui les rapporteurs de cet avis
préparer au sein de la commission
Environnement du CESU messieurs Serge Le
quaio Pascal kikenv qui est neuf ainsi
que le président de la commission
monsieur boucheron
notre président Rémy pointeau ayant un
empêchement j'assure la présidence de
notre séance du jour je rappelle que
cette audition fait l'objet
officiel et d'une retransmission nous
vous remercions d'avoir accepté de venir
nous présenter votre rapport qui
nourrira notre réflexion en vue de la
rédaction du rapport de notre mission
qui devrait être adoptée fin juin début
juillet messieurs
un questionnaire vous a été adressé pour
préciser nos interrogations mais nous
vous laisserons d'abord présenter vos
travaux et vos 23 préconisations nous
sommes également très intéressés par
votre regard sur le plan haut du
gouvernement de 53 mesures qui a été
présenté le mois dernier et qui rejoint
en partie vos propositions je vais donc
passer la parole à RVG notre rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente je vous
renouvelle également mes remerciements
pour votre disponibilité je remercie
également à nos collègues qui sont qui
sont présents aujourd'hui
vous avez tous conscience qu'on est dans
un moment effectivement particulier le
16e a aussi
participé justement à créer on va dire
cette résonance politique sur un sujet
qui prend une profondeur de plus en plus
importante parfois malheureusement
compte tenu d'une sécheresse hivernale
qui impacte déjà plusieurs départements
je voudrais tout d'abord vous remercier
aussi pour la qualité de vos travaux et
vous dire aussi
l'intérêt et le souhait que nous avons
au niveau du Parlement et aussi au
niveau du Sénat de pouvoir échanger avec
le CESU sur
sur ces orientations et sur les
préconisations que vous avez pu faire au
travers de votre rapport alors nous
avons un timing un peu contenu
compte tenu des questions au
Gouvernement donc je vais me permettre
de rentrer directement si vous voulez
bien dans le vif du sujet au travers
bien sûr des questionnements qu'on a pu
vous soumettre et puis vous allez
peut-être avoir quelques propos
liminaires par rapport à la prise
d'initiative que vous avez pu avoir et
puis je vous propose de rentrer
directement après les présentations
d'usage sur justement pourquoi cette
initiative au niveau du sujet
aujourd'hui et puis comment vous avez
apprendre en l'occurrence ce sujet et
notamment quelles sont les premières
remarques que vous pouvez faire
notamment en termes de connaissances à
la fois du sujet et puis peut-être les
approches que vous avez pu avoir sur les
gouvernances et notamment par exemple
sur la généralisation des sages mais on
ira un peu plus loin bien sûr au niveau
du questionnement je vous en prie
mesdames et messieurs députés de ma
présidente sénateur minuscuses on va
trop vite
on va être efficace et du coup au moins
un petit peu trop vite boum
les parlementaires comme ça ça évite de
faire
merci de nous avoir invité sur le mode
contexte sur le le la prise initiative
que vous le savez le CESU à la capacité
de s'auto saisir ou d'être saisie par le
gouvernement et également par le
Parlement sur différentes questions on
est en ce moment par exemple saisi par
le gouvernement sur la question de la
consommation durable également sur la
question des NTG les nouvelles
techniques génomiques dont on remettra
nos rapports dans les prochaines
semaines et dans sa capacité
d'initiative propre le CESU avait décidé
l'année dernière de lancer différents
travaux
un premier sur les questions des
politiques de sobriété comment on
imagine des politiques qui peuvent
favoriser la sobriété au sens large pas
que la question de l'énergie mais plus
largement sur l'ensemble des ressources
des modes de vie etc et donc c'est un
contexte qui est important pour
comprendre aussi l'approche qui il y a
dans cette avis sur l'eau qui est venue
juste après et qui s'inscrit également
dans un contexte d'alerte on avait voulu
à l'époque avant finalement qu'on
commence à rentrer dans cette crise de
l'eau que l'on connaît depuis plusieurs
mois on avait voulu alerter les pouvoirs
publics et le gouvernement sur le sujet
donc on avait déjà fait une alerte il y
a un an et puis du coup qu'on a traduit
par un avis un petit peu plus
circonstancié donc ça c'est important à
avoir en tête dans le
dans le champ et l'approche que l'on a
pu développer au CESU et puis peut-être
pour terminer ce propos liminaire très
succinct rappelait qu'au sein de la
commission Environnement on a évidemment
les représentations les représentants à
la fois des entreprises mais aussi des
syndicats des agriculteurs des
associations environnementales sur
famille etc et donc l'idée de dans la
mesure du possible et d'essayer de créer
des consensus sur nos préconisations et
puis parfois sur un certain nombre de
points on n'a pas forcément encore
réussi à trouver les voies de passage en
tout cas c'est vraiment l'esprit du
travail dans lequel s'inscrit le CESU
donc pour entrer plus précisément dans
vos dans vos questionnements et
présenter nos préconisations moi je vous
propose d'entendre Pascal guynef et
Serge Le Kyo qui ont
eu l'honneur de rapporter cet avis
bonjour monsieur dame sénatrice et
sénateur
oui donc on s'est intéressé à la
question
très directement il y a on va dire une
petite année donc en cours de l'année
2022 qui s'est montré très très
problématique en termes d'eau à la fois
d'ailleurs en termes de sécheresse mais
aussi quelques événements
intenses en termes de de pluie d'orage
etc le César a assez assez souvent
regardé les choses autour de l'eau mais
peut-être le plus le plus remarquable ou
remarqué c'était quelque chose en 2013
la gestion de l'usage de l'eau en
agriculture pour vous donner ça ou la
question des usages à éviter
mise en avant avec déjà des des
recommandations autour de l'agroécologie
de la préservation de de l'environnement
et de l'eau alors comment le plus simple
c'est de regarder un petit peu notre
plan très vite fait donc on a commencé
on a souhaité regarder les aspects
scientifiques refaire un tour de face au
changement climatique qui me fait partie
de notre titre de notre de notre tweet
pour voir pour de la culture et pouvoir
jusqu'où on savait les choses et là où
on savait pas donc on a pris pas mal de
de
d'incertitude dans les données qu'on a
donc ça veut dire de travaux à améliorer
ne serait-ce par exemple la
régionalisation des des commandes des
simulations
et savoir un peu la France comment les
couper en deux ça s'était connu mais
jusqu'où elle est coupée en deux donc on
a un petit peu regardé ça
on a vu qu'il y avait encore du travail
de ce côté là et d'ailleurs le président
de la République dans son dans son
allocution à parler de régionalisation
des des données du GIEC
explorent deux enfin tous ces tous ces
travaux scientifiques pour améliorer
notre savoir
en termes de changement climatique et
les conséquences bien sûr sur sur l'eau
ensuite on a fait un point sur sur les
ressources sur les
[Applaudissements]
usages et donc forcément les conflits
d'usage ou là on a essayé de
s'intéresser et ça peut être forcément
simple à donc à tous les usagers de
l'eau sans essayer de se concentrer sur
l'agriculture
et pourtant on revient très vite
l'agriculture quand on parle d'eau ça
revient très vite on a quand même
regarder la microélectronique du côté de
Grenoble solitech et STM qui avait des
besoins en eau et
ultra purs donc un peu comment comment
ils font ça avec un conflit qui a
commencé là-bas
qui continue mais quelle est un peu
moins hostile que dans d'autres endroits
de France bien sûr les les conflits avec
l'agriculture on a décidé les usages de
tel le tourisme pourra peut-être
développer un petit peu là-dessus puis
d'autres d'autres usages on va pas faire
tout le tour il y en a tellement on a
peu travaillé sur sur l'électricité il y
a eu il y avait eu un autre un autre une
autre saisie innovant donc ça n'a pas
été notre notre première notre premier
nos premières interrogations
et ensuite ça a été un deuxième point
sur qu'elle trouvait qu'il y avait quand
même du travail mais on n'arrive pas à
convertir c'est tout ce qui est
pollution et du coup on a été depuis la
petite année où on travaille là-dessus
rattrapé par beaucoup de d'actualité
qu'elle soit législatives qu'elle soit
les les bifaces dernièrement qui n'ont
pas grand chose avec l'agriculture mais
qui participent de la de la pollution de
l'eau et puis sur tout ce qui est autour
des intrants agricoles donc on a on a
suivi tout ça on a regardé ça
d'un peu près bien sûr
rénovation des réseaux d'eau
la réhute là on a beaucoup travaillé sur
cette aspect là on va y revenir sans
doute avec vos questions bon et un petit
peu un peu aussi bien sûr sur
l'organisation là la gouvernance comme
on dit souvent
bon
puisque
de tous les usagers au bout d'un moment
encore une fois l'agriculture revient et
puis on s'est interrogé quand même sur
les assises de l'eau versus le varen le
varen de l'eau en voyant là quand même
ça a été on va dire prolongé par le par
le rapport de la Cour des comptes là où
on voit bien alors c'est la sens et tout
ce qu'on veut mais on voit bien qu'il y
a quelque chose derrière qu'on n'arrive
pas à bien à bien dévaluer nous on
appelle ça
[Musique]
on a essayé puis je vais m'arrêter là
que tu vas pouvoir continuer on a essayé
de faire un on a fait une table ronde
avec les
donc FNSEA
qui avait Coordination rurale et
configurations
ça a été assez
calme mais parce que les choses n'ont
pas été dites donc là encore une fois
même en mettant tous ensemble les choses
se pratique donc ça quand même ça c'est
quand même fait un petit peu lorsqu'il a
fallu faire des amendements etc on avait
encore une fois senti cette
pause solitude parce que c'est quand
même chez nous c'est un peu comme chez
vous c'est c'est gentil mais on voit
bien avec donc un vote de la vie bien
voter mais sauf par les sauf par les
agriculteurs agricultures intensives et
puis de l'autre côté
d'autres qui voulaient qu'on aille un
peu plus loin aussi
[Musique]
tu veux peut-être préciser tes choses
merci Pascal tu as bien expliqué le
point de vue du rapport on va peut-être
attendre vos questions pour vous
éclairer un peu mieux mais ce que il y a
peut-être un spectacle trop développé
c'est que on a aussi voulu pointer que
il fallait que
améliorer la recherche dans le domaine
de l'eau parce que finalement il y avait
assez peu de
documentation disponibles ils sont très
dispersés donc on fait des
préconisations pour que tout ça se soit
il y a plus de coordination il est aussi
il y a tout un aspect qu'on a bien
développé c'est que il y a quand même
une certaine carence des services de
l'État en moteur de contrôle ça on le
pointe aussi donc avec des émissions des
effectifs dans les dans les
administrations publiques bon on
s'aperçoit que il y a quand même un
problème qui qui se pose quoi c'est vrai
que rebondir immédiatement sur vos
propos puisque du jeu c'est que on
essaye d'approfondir à un certain nombre
de sujets puisque on partage un grand
nombre des problématiques que vous avez
pu aborder donc on va aller le plus
directement possible tout d'abord donc
vous parliez là vous mettez en suspens
la qualité des contrôles des services de
l'État ce que vous pouvez nous préciser
dans quel domaine plus plus précisément
vous évoquez aussi en termes de
connaissances et de recherche c'est un
sujet que nous souhaitons également
approfondir le but du jeu c'est de
donner peut-être une meilleure
lisibilité meilleure complémentarité des
moyens qui sont accordés aujourd'hui au
niveau de la recherche qu'elles soient
fondamentale ou qu'elle soit appliquées
et de quelle manière elles peuvent
véritablement diffuser au niveau des
filières professionnelles au travers de
la Recherche et Développement donc c'est
aussi un sujet qui effectivement
important et puis vous l'abordiez
également dans vos propos liminaires sur
la connaissance des données le niveau
d'information est-ce que vous avez
rencontré des difficultés est-ce qu'il y
a des niveaux d'information que vous
auriez souhaité avoir sur lesquels vous
avez eu des des problématiques
particulières sachant que ce qu'on
essaye d'approfondir c'est la meilleure
connaissance par bassin versant faire en
sorte qu'on maîtrise le mieux possible à
la fois la quantité d'eau disponible et
en même temps son utilisation et comment
la croiser des chemins peut s'organiser
dans une bonne gouvernance en termes
d'objectifs partagés avec l'ensemble des
usages voilà
répondre tout de suite par rapport
à la question de la recherche il voulait
et puis du manque de moyens d'État si
vous voulez ce qui est ressorti beaucoup
dans nos auditions et dès la première
audition avant même qu'on se fasse une
auto saisie on avait
auditionné le président de l'Agence de
l'Eau Rhône Méditerranée Corse et on
était arrivé au constat que si vous
voulez on ne trouve que ce que l'on
cherche et comment on cherche très peu
en matière de molécules polluant l'eau
on trouve très peu parce qu'on cherche
pas enfin l'année 2022 pour ça a été
assez remarquable pour notre saisine
parce que finalement au cours de l'année
il y a eu énormément de choses qui ont
été révélées notamment les pollutions
très fortes avec les métabolites de
pesticides le S métal au chlore qui fait
aujourd'hui dans il y a toute la
polémique qui a autour
des déclarations communistes a pu faire
concernant l'ancêtre mais il y a eu
aussi les préfaces qui étaient je vais
auditionner le
comment le président du comité
comité de bassin justement de Rhône
Méditerranée et donc qui qui semblait ne
pas connaître la position préface donc
tout ça c'est sorti dans les médias non
à l'époque quand il y avait posé la
question ils avaient dit non il pensait
que l'eau notamment dans l'agglomération
de Lyon était tout à fait potable il y
avait pas de problème bon la réalité
c'est que tout ça c'est sorti quelques
jours après le 11 audition quoi oui oui
donc oui donc voilà donc si vous voulez
on s'est aperçu que il y a il faut
améliorer la recherche il faut laisser
les organismes de contrôle notamment il
faut laisser dans ces faire son travail
quoi il faut laisser les scientifiques à
travailler et il faut investiguer plus
que ce qu'on a fait il faut sortir enfin
de notre point de vue c'est un peu ça le
président Boucheron vous l'a dit nous ce
qu'on a voulu faire c'était un avis
court mais un avis d'alerte
et on pense qu'il y a un véritable
problème en matière de qualité des eaux
d'ailleurs la France ne respecte pas la
directive ou de l'Union européenne la
DCE 98 83 donc on a déjà un problème
avec des pollutions chimiques les
pollutions aussi avec les trades
notamment et que donc il y a il faut
vraiment améliorer la situation mais
jusqu'à présent nous ce qu'on a eu le
sentiment si vous voulez c'est qu'il y
avait une sorte de déni collectif un
refus de voir la réalité en face quoi
alors évidemment nous notre point de vue
c'est qu'il faut pas voler les
populations mais il faut pas rester
inactif il faut agir pour améliorer la
qualité voilà et pour et pour les
services de l'État si vous voulez
prendre les agences de l'eau ils ont
perdu depuis 4 ou 5 ans 30% de leurs
effectifs ça c'est un chiffre qui nous a
été donné aussi par Laurent Roy donc le
président de l'Agence de l'Eau Rhône
militaire année et tous les services que
soit le rugby c'est là qui sont chargés
des contrôles des instructions des
inspecteurs de l'eau notamment
avec les diminutions des effectifs dans
la fonction publique de l'État
évidemment font qu'aujourd'hui souvent
ces services ne sont pas vraiment en
capacité de faire un travail
la partie peut-être quantité ou
simulation donc sur la quantité et les
simulations
climatiques
quelque chose qui nous paraît encore
assez assez flou vous savez les plus 1,5
degrés plus de degrés plus 2,5 + 3,8
pour la France et cette cette barrière
plus de degrés et là c'est quelque part
derrière c'est la catastrophe donc plus
de degrés c'est pour le Global en France
on va aller plus vite
c'est pas c'est pas sympathique comme
comme chemin mais on va aller plus vite
que ça faire là et moi par exemple on
n'a pas réussi à savoir si les deux
degrés qui sont des normalement des des
frontières des des jalons pour la
biodiversité au-dessus ça se bimbe
beaucoup plus vite alors du coup en
France on va dépasser ça on sait pas
trop quand
donc ça va plus vite donc qu'est-ce qui
va plus vite donc ça on a un petit peu
de mal à concevoir ça bien sûr nous dit
comme biodiversité il y a des espèces
c'est déjà le cas qui meurent on n'a pas
besoin de parler de d'arbres qui vont
plus être ça va plus être les bonnes les
bonnes au bon endroit donc ça c'est très
long un arbre à faire pousser qui
s'occupe de ça
donc qui s'occupe de ça pour l'instant
on a pas eu beaucoup de réponses il y a
beaucoup d'idées il y a des idées de
réponse on va dire stratégique on a un
peu de mal à
en trouver ça discute mais c'est pas
encore il y a pas encore un plan et pas
encore ça pour les arbres c'est long et
il s'agirait pas que les arbres soient
haut comme ça en 2050 quoi là on a raté
on a raté la course qu'on a monte donc
cette course contre la montre là elle
est pas encore bien à notre avis mesuré
sachant que si tout le monde parle de
2050 parlant 2050 donc en France
peut-être il fera 2,7 2,2 degrés de plus
que avant la avant on va dire début du
siècle du 20e siècle hein donc avec ça
qu'est-ce qu'on fait hein alors il y a
une petite alerte mais finalement elle
est passée assez
par le ministre monsieur bechut qui a
parlé des 3 8 4 degrés en 2100 donc déjà
intéressant c'est à dire qu'il a dépassé
ce que le gai dit même c'est pas facile
parce que chaque fois qu'on parle du
Jack il faut penser que c'est mondial et
foramener ça à déjà la terre par rapport
à la mer et à l'Europe qui se réchauffe
plus vite donc tout ça nous paraît pas
très très clair mais on arrive à deviner
quand même la tendance par contre la
pente de la tendance c'est pas très très
clair donc voilà sur le côté
scientifique des choses des choses à
voir on a aussi regardé par une 2022
c'est intéressant
parce que c'est vraiment une année
exceptionnelle alors on l'a vécu mais
même dans les chiffres les prévisions
GIEC rapport intermédiaire donna un plus
1,7 d'ailleurs on entend souvent le plus
1,7 quand on regarde plus 2,9 où elles
étaient car alors a priori peut-être un
manque de
d'interrogations sur la météo les vents
venus du sud un peu qui se passe en
Espagne ces jours-ci donc comment
intégrer dans les climatologie qui parle
de
moyennes qui enlèvent les les piques
comment la rétablir dans le dans le dans
le schéma parce que finalement les
agriculteurs si on prend eux ils ont
besoin de quelque chose de d'année en
année voir un peu plus ils font
plusieurs écoles donc tout ça nous
paraît quand même devoir pouvoir
progresser et je finis sur peut-être non
sur deux choses ça par exemple c'est aux
prévisions saisonnières je sais pas si
vous regardez ça de temps en temps donc
vous allez prévisions à 3 jours 7 jours
8 jours les prévisions les moyennes
plusieurs dizaines d'années et puis vous
allez prévisions saisonnière c'est très
intéressant mais aujourd'hui quand vous
prenez celle qui nous amène jusqu'à
juillet aujourd'hui vous avez une
tendance plus chaude côté méditerranéen
et puis le reste on sait pas
précipitation aucune aucune tendance
donc ça c'est vraiment un travail
scientifique qui alors là c'est beaucoup
de travail beaucoup de simulations
beaucoup de mais ça avance et sans doute
il faut travailler ça pour être plus
prospectif
juste pour reformuler vous validez de
toute façon l'idée qu'il faut conforter
un modèle qui soit le plus performant
possible en termes de production de
données notamment à l'échelle des
bassins
d'accord voilà c'est vraiment le vide la
préconisation 8 pour répondre
précisément effectivement on a été
surpris finalement de la pâte très bonne
connaissance à la fois des quantités
d'eau des prélèvements qui ont été faits
et ça nous semble essentiel d'avoir une
meilleure visibilité notamment en temps
réel pour qu'on puisse
demain dans des crises qu'on imagine
plus fréquentes être capable de piloter
au plus juste
cette gestion de l'eau donc là on a un
besoin d'améliorer la connaissance
et les informations et même en préconise
de les rendre aussi public pour
faciliter l'accès à l'ensemble des
acteurs
et donc de vulgarisation pour nous pour
vous nous parlez assez long comment
faire pour raccourcir ce temps en plus
dans la dans l'actualité
très bien sur ce sujet on peut
effectivement partager on va faire
peut-être un petit stop and go pour que
nos collègues madame la Présidente si
vous en êtes d'accord plus
poser leurs questions
juste par rapport à votre dernier de
votre dernier propos moi je pense que
plus que la quantité c'est la façon dont
c'est eau tombe sur le sol
on a moins de quantité c'est certain
mais surtout on a des périodes très très
longues pendant lesquelles il pleut pas
et quand il pleut ce sont des orages
monstrueux ou l'eau pénètre pas l'eau
circule et c'est peut-être là-dessus
qu'il faut se poser des questions
[Musique]
alors dans votre
dans votre rapport vous vous dressez un
tableau assez sombre en fait de la
qualité de l'eau sur quoi vous avez sans
doute raison d'ailleurs notamment
s'agissant des pollutions nitrates
pesticides et autres et du coup en fait
vous vous proposez un certain nombre de
de mesures
je pense à la réduction des cheptels
pour lutter contre les apports d'azote
on connaît bien Serge
et dans les zones vulnérables et donc
vous proposez un certain nombre de
mesures assez radical si je veux dire en
la matière
est-ce que vous pensez sincèrement mais
sûrement que dans le cadre de la
reconquête de la qualité de l'eau sur
laquelle nous travaillons depuis déjà
des années
il faut employer ce que vous proposez
c'est-à-dire la manière forte ou est-ce
que il vaut pas mieux en fait proposer
des mesures plus soft entre guillemets
allant vers les cophytos la protection
des captages prioritaires un certain
nombre de choses comme ça
et non pas parce que là vous y êtes bon
coeur quoi je veux dire donc
je peux répondre comment dire alors
c'est la fameuse préconisation 14 je
pense qu'elle est malue non mais c'est
le problème avec cette préconisation là
c'est que on demande bien une diminution
de cheptel dans les zones qui sont déjà
saturées mais on demande pas une
diminution globale et chacun demande à
redéploiement des chapelles en gros
c'est ça c'est à dire que il est pas
question que
bien sûr voilà donc c'est NON NON donc
c'est pour ça que c'est
la rédaction telle qu'elle est je vous
invite à bien la relire je pense que
ceux qui ont pas voté notre avis
justement ce sont appuyé là-dessus mais
je pense qu'ils ont fait un mauvais
procès
ils n'ont pas voté voilà mais en disant
justement dans leur communication si on
regarde bien comment ils ont communiqué
en disant que on demandait la démission
des chefs c'est pas vrai c'est pas écrit
comme ça du tout c'est diminuant les
cheptel dans les zones sursaturées
notamment là tu connais bien voilà mais
avec un redéploiement voilà un redéplomb
et surtout ce qu'on préconise parce que
ce qui était apparu dans tous les
auditions qu'on a eu qui ressortait sans
arrêt c'est que si on veut
garder l'eau par rapport à ce que vous
avez dit il faut surtout travailler à la
qualité des sols et tout le monde il n'y
a pas que les agronomes qui nous l'ont
dit même les
mêmes comment dire Madame abette
notamment un qui était allé climatologue
elle a dit on ne pourra pas
maintenir les quantités d'eau je dans le
pays si jamais les soldes ne sont pas en
capacité des donc du coup ce que ce
qu'on propose nous évidemment donc
première ambiguïté qu'il faut lever
c'est que on est absolument pas pour la
dimension du capital même on pense même
que notamment les accords de
libre-échange c'est un peu ce qu'on a
répondu à ce qui nous critiquent
là-dessus on leur a dit c'est pas
redéploiement des chapital dans le pays
il y a des des régions où il y a plus il
y a plus sur un cheptel parce que voilà
mais ce sont souvent les accords de
libre-échange qui font qu'il y a des
importations de notamment de viande qui
qui ouais voilà qui font tomber des
filières quoi en gros mais c'est pas
c'est pas parce que on demande de et
voilà et après il faut raison garder
c'est à dire que dans des zones sur
saturées et en cela on a fait que
reprendre les recommandations de la Cour
des comptes de la Cour des comptes a
fait un excellent rapport sur les algues
vertes en Bretagne donc ils ont fait un
bilan il montre bien que on n'arrive pas
les les différents plans qui ont coûté
beaucoup d'argent public de bons
n'arrivent pas à traiter le problème
mais une de leurs préconisations la Cour
des comptes qu'on a repris d'ailleurs
c'était de dire que il y a des zones sur
saturées il faut il faut arrêter quoi
faire des extensions de l'élevage
surtout en plus quand ces extensions
souvent sont des dérogatoires avec le
droit quoi et c'est des préfets qui
autorisent des extensions d'élevage dans
des zones déjà sur saturées mais la
question sous-jacente de Monsieur Alain
Cadec c'est aussi la question de
l'acceptabilité et de comment on crée
des conditions d'aller ensemble vers des
objectifs qui soient les plus partagées
possibles un des sujets que nous
évoquons de manière assez régulière au
niveau de la mission d'information c'est
de voir comment nous pourrions créer des
conditions d'un contrat d'objectifs et
de performance qui permettrait d'engager
l'ensemble des parties prenantes sous
couvert bien sûr parce que tous les
usagers ont les mêmes besoins d'assurer
une ressource si tenter qu'on puisse
l'assurer à un moment donné sur ces
notions là qu'en pensez-vous est-ce que
ça nous semble ça nous semble des voix
intéressantes
juste un mot sur le point de départ de
notre travail c'est que quand on a
démarré cet avis on n'avait pas connu la
crise de l'été dernier donc ça se
voulait un avis prospectif en se disant
demain mais au sens dans 5 10 15 ans ce
sera difficile il faut qu'on se prépare
et qu'on gère mieux notre eau et en fait
l'actualité ne nous a fait comprendre
que c'était déjà là je crois que plus on
attend et plus ce sera dur donc
embarquer tout le monde c'est absolument
essentiel mais il faut qu'on soit
exigeant dans la manière dont on peut
embarquer tout le monde parce qu'il faut
pas qu'on se contente
de petites choses sachant que la crise
elle est finalement arrivée beaucoup
plus vite que ce qu'on aurait pu
imaginer au début et je crois que plus
on va attendre plus ça va être tendu les
citoyens les ménages qui vont avoir
besoin d'eau les industriels les
agriculteurs tous les acteurs et donc ce
qu'on voit quand même c'est qu'il va
falloir qu'on ait des logiques de
partage et plus ça va être tendu plus ce
sera difficile de vouloir partager une
ressource qui diminue donc je crois
qu'il faut c'est vraiment l'esprit le
point de départ de notre travail c'était
d'avoir vraiment un point d'alerte cela
nécessité d'avancer assez vite même très
vite sur le sujet
par rapport parce que le vrai sujet
finalement c'est l'accompagnement des
agriculteurs en gros en gros c'est ça
voilà donc si vous voulez je pense qu'il
y a aucun agriculteur qui a envie de
boire l'eau qui est pas potable en gros
et en plus comme on l'a dit souvent dans
nos sorties sans arrêt dans nos
auditions c'est que
l'utilisation massive de pesticides
voilà et qui pose un sacré problème
comme le dit le professeur sultan il y a
pas de il y a pas de victimes et
pesticides on est tous victimes du
pesticides à travers l'air l'eau on boit
tous de l'eau du robinet il y a de voilà
et après croire que on peut étendre
autant de pesticides qu'on a fait si
vous voulez en pensant que ça n'aurait
pas de conséquence sur l'eau évidemment
la pollution de l'eau et la santé
publique c'était une vision alors après
on sait on connaît les les méthodes pour
s'en sortir il faut aller vers
l'agroécologie il faut accompagner des
agriculteurs dans cette transformation
très importante il faut surtout en
capacité
là de ces jeux je pense qu'il peut y
participer et puis vous aussi
c'est de dire que il y a des
externalités négatives qui coûtent
considérablement plus cher que si on est
des directement des agriculteurs
c'est-à-dire en gros on parle que
l'agriculture productivisme produit
environ 30% de la biologie mais si on
était capable de bien quantifier les
externalités négatives que ça veut dire
en terme de qualité de la nourriture et
puis de conséquences que ça pour la
santé publique notamment il y a pas
photo la groupie est plus rentable si
vous voulez mais seulement il faut que
ce soit un contrat avec la société il
faut que ce soit mis sur la table qu'on
dise les agriculteurs qui
transforment leur mode de production
doivent être accompagnés financièrement
et là c'est là qu'on retombe alors nous
on n'a pas avoir d'expé celui-là mais ça
vous concerne évidemment au premier chef
vous les parlementaires c'est qu'il faut
aussi qu'il y ait une cohérence des
politiques publiques c'est à dire qu'on
peut pas demander aux agriculteurs de
faire des efforts et là on voit bien
avec le bio en ce moment qui est en
difficulté voilà donc il faut aussi
qu'il y a un contrat
voilà mais et d'être capable de dire
la nourriture de qualité de l'eau de
qualité ça a un coût c'est ce coup-là il
faut essayer d'être capable de l'assumer
de dire voilà on a des agriculteurs
parce que on veut que vous soyez bien
nourri voilà et
t'en vouloir être provocateur ça a un
coût mais à l'heure actuelle en période
d'inflation ce coup il se répercute sur
le fait qu'on achète moins des produits
bio et donc il y a bien une réalité
aussi du marché qui fait que à un moment
donné qu'est-ce qu'on fait par rapport à
ces réalités du marché alors c'est d'une
part par rapport à l'accessibilité
alimentaire pour les gens comment le
moyen comment on fait parce que si ça
coûte plus cher comment on fait comment
on accompagne ces personnes et d'autre
part par rapport à l'agroécologie etc
sur lequel on peut être nombreux à
souhaiter qu'il y ait le développement
de ce type de pratique il n'en demeure
pas moins qui a quand même malgré tout
des rendements qui sont moins importants
donc comment fait-on également pour
adapter les modèles c'est la question
clé
sur les rendements la question
climatique était essentielle de toute
façon avec moins d'eau les rendements
vont baisser alors est-ce qu'il faut
accumuler les deux ça c'est une vraie
question nous on estime que il faut
améliorer la qualité des sols pour
retenir l'eau qui va se trouver rare et
ça c'est plus de l'agriculture intensive
donc on a on l'a bien vu on voit bien
très rapidement on voit le débat entre
l'agriculture intensive tournée vers les
rendements et tournés quelque part vers
alors on a parlé de souveraineté
alimentaire puis au bout de trois
minutes de discussion c'est arrivé sur
la souveraineté diplomatique
c'est-à-dire qu'on est on fait de la
marchand d'art du marchandage l'exemple
cité mets-toi avec l'Algérie donc on
vend du blé contre allez du gaz à ce
moment-là donc on comprend l'idée mais
nous on n'était pas là-dessus enfin on
est sur quelque chose c'est vrai
d'agroécologie là-dedans il y a écrit
écologie donc on c'est un peu la
direction qu'on a prise dans notre dans
notre avis que les terres redeviennent
arables redevienne productive sans y
rajouter tous les entrants donc ça c'est
une position de départ et elle est
difficile à tenir et on a du mal au bout
de 5 minutes avec nos copains
l'agriculture on s'engue rapidement ils
vont nous répondre ce que vous avez dit
sinon on produit pas ça va être les
importations mais on va dire ça c'est
des choix politiques ça nous notre idée
c'est bien sûr on les met en avant bien
sûr il faut accompagner alors là dessus
par contre on peut peut-être rajouter
contre nous on n'a pas montré aucune
animosité à aider à accompagner même sur
un temps long c'est vrai que on peut
être
des environnementsalistes les écoles
sans doute aller plus vite qu'on
pourrait faire de toute façon donc là on
demande un plan
à terme ben je crois qu'il y a des
études pour 2040 2050 il y en a déjà eu
des études pour 2040 2050 repr et puis
faisons ce qui avait été dit les assises
de l'eau par exemple disent des choses
là
donc il faut avancer et pas comme ça
nous sommes tous favorables aujourd'hui
à accompagner les modèles de production
pour qu'ils puissent s'adapter aux
nouvelles réalités des enjeux
climatiques
écologique
mais on est parfois confronté aussi à
des logiques de marché voire de
réglementation européenne alors actuelle
accompagné la filière agricole c'est
aussi se confronter à une logique de
concurrence européenne donc il y a c'est
aussi un vrai sujet bien sûr je finis
juste en citant en parlant de maïs nous
pour faire du maïs ou de l'eau beaucoup
d'eau est-ce qu'il faut se poser de la
question de faire du maïs
tel que c'est fait aujourd'hui en
Charente peut-être dans les côtes
les côtes-dames mais je me suis pas
trompé là ça doit encore durer un bon
moment je pense que cette année ça
devrait pour le maïs mais où est-ce que
ça c'est une question que vous avez
abordé totale d'une question
scientifique il faut qu'ils nous disent
où on peut faire combien combien de
flottes il faut pour faire ça et combien
il y en a et si c'est pas disponible à
cet endroit là bien entendu concerté
avec tout le tout les gens du lieu il
faut arrêter
alors on peut bien sûr dans la dans la
transition essayez de trouver l'eau qui
manque bon ça c'est une mais avec avec
un objectif je crois que en Vendée ils
ont commencé à travailler sur
des autorisations de de de bassin de
substitution j'ai mis les deux mots
exprès et puis en face on commence à
parler de d'agroécologie petitement mais
c'est pour que ça commence petitement
d'objectif partagé qui permettrait de
voilà il faut savoir se causer pour
avancer sur ces sujets là je voulais
vous dire le temps passe le temps passe
un rapport un rapport agriculture
européenne sans pesticides pour 2050 et
c'est un excellent rapport qui a été
fait qui vient de sortir quelques mois
de linerae nous on pense qu'il faut
s'appuyer sur les travaux et
scientifiques comme ça quoi
merci beaucoup madame le Présidente
je suis arrivé un petit peu en cours
donc vous m'excusez j'ai pas lu tout
votre rapport cela étant dit j'ai pas
l'impression de voir beaucoup de choses
sur la réutilisation de l'eau
potentiellement il y a il y a il y a un
vrai potentiel à ce niveau là les
stations d'épuration vous voyez dans les
villes on pourrait utiliser cette eau là
pour arroser les plantes enfin tout ça
c'est des des milliers des milliers de
mètres cubes d'eau gagner et et
là-dessus je vois pas beaucoup de
préconisations alors que il y a une
vraie économie à faire et j'avais un
autre sujet aussi
vous parler beaucoup de pollution
agricoles mais moi je vois rien enfin je
vois pas grand chose non plus pour
réduire nos propres pollutions or nous
actuellement on est on est un des pays
qui enfouit le plus de déchets
dans nos sols et ça c'est une vraie
source de pollution et ça je ne vois
rien sur le sujet effectivement il y a
quand même moyen de réduire nos propres
déchets en tout cas d'arrêter
d'enfouissement qui est qui à mon avis
tout autant préjudiciable que les
pollutions agricoles dont vous parlez
presque on a pas traité tout le sujet
vous avez raison mais on a traité de la
réhute
et même des zones non conventionnelles à
un moment donné on a on a posé des
questions sur le retraitement ça coûte
très cher donc on sait faire on retraite
qui va payer c'est plus cher que l'eau
potable donc qui va payer déjà les
retraitements et puis après les
kilomètres de tuyaux qui va falloir
installer pour aller de la de l'usine de
retraitement des eaux usées vers
l'utilisateur alors qu'ici c'est
l'agriculteur on voit déjà les
kilomètres ça peut être un peu plus
récent un peu plus court si par exemple
si dans
l'utilisation des eaux usées ou des eaux
de pluie dans les villes par exemple là
il y a un circuit plus court il y a les
systèmes de tonneau vous voyez enfin
vous voyez ils vont chercher enfin ils
pourraient récupérer l'eau et arroser
vous voyez dans les villes on a comme ça
avec il y a un petit tracteur à toutes
ces Zola ne sont pas réutilisables et
c'est dommage parce qu'il y a un
potentiel aussi un potentiel donc on a
regardé ça on s'est heurté à la discuté
non puisqu'on a on a mis une
préconisition
la 17 où on demande de leur
réutilisation sans doute pas dans les
proportions du président de la
République à 10% ça on trouve ça très
ambitieux regardons
voyons le montage économique à mon avis
n'est pas complètement évident
mais c'est certainement une des
solutions on n'a pas envie non plus on a
on n'a pas été trop loin dans la
comparaison c'est ce qu'on dit il sera
elle c'est je sais plus 90 % les spams
ils ont une très grosse obligation
puisque ils ont plus d'eau enfin encore
moins que nous nous on doit commencer on
pense par la sobriété les économies ça
ça fait partie de nouvelles ressources
mais qui coûte tellement cher qu'il faut
faire attention à commencer par la
sobriété c'était un peu ce que faire des
eaux réutiliser de les eaux usées
retraitées pour faire du maïs en
Charente ça nous paraît pas
à cause du réchauffement climatique
on est tous d'accord et on attend
surtout la sortie des décrets pour que
ça soit enfin applicable en milieu
industriel et il y a des attentes qui
soient très fortes le temps passe je me
permets d'avancer un petit peu sur des
questions qu'on vraiment nous
souhaitions aborder avec vous
tout d'abord sur la notion aujourd'hui
de tarification différenciées et par
rapport à ce qui était annoncé au niveau
du plan o est-ce que vous avez des
remarques particulières à nous faire
effectivement sur sur le sujet quand une
la nature aussi de vous adhérents c'est
intéressant à voir là-dessus et puis un
sujet que nous essayons de pousser
aujourd'hui en termes de planification
c'est comment mieux intégrer les
politiques de l'eau dans les documents
d'urbanisme et notamment les scottes et
les pluies est-ce que vous avez un avis
éventuellement sur le sujet
oui c'est la partie estarifications
sociales progressive de l'eau c'est une
de nos préconisations à ce stade c'était
une préconisation on se réjouit que dans
le plan haut ça a été repris et que le
gouvernement a prévu de saisir le CESU
pour rentrer dans les modalités donc
pour l'instant on attend la signature de
la saisine pour pouvoir rentrer dans le
détail des modalités plus précises de
mise en oeuvre mais c'est évidemment une
piste qui nous semblait intéressante à
poursuivre
la première chose qu'on prend c'est il
s'est passé des choses loi Brotte et
puis la corruption 2019 il s'est passé
beaucoup d'expérience déjà donc on fait
le bilan il y a ceux qui n'ont pas pris
non plus qui n'ont pas rentrer dans
l'expérimentation pourquoi on sait qu'il
y a des problèmes de qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire on va dire les précaires
on est bien
d'accordier alors pas tout à fait la
même chose non vous avez raison donc un
peu puisqu'on a pas encore compensé
vraiment les études mais on voit qu'il y
a des choses qui sont faites d'abord on
fera d'abord un bilan en train de
regarder regardez ça c'est clair qu'on a
on n'a pas encore assez traîner sur le
côté on si on a mis pas de tarification
dégressive donc ça touche pas seulement
l'eau
domestique mais toutes les eaux parce
qu'on a comme on sait que les prix pas
le même selon la quantité qu'on prend et
on va dire historiquement économiquement
plus on en prend assez cher là c'est à
l'envers il faut il faut faire changer
dans les bonnes institutions et puis
voir que ça veut dire ça on va voir des
réactions évidemment les industriels
alors si eux on l'a mis dans notre
rapport si le traite leur eau à limite
ça fait déjà un bon un bon point de prix
si il y a un gros travail sur je vais
chercher de l'eau ultra pur pour faire
de la microélectronique bon bah là ça se
négocie ça se travaille c'est quand même
l'eau qui n'ira pas dans la
potabilisation donc on a plein de choses
comme ça très localement à regarder
voilà c'est vraiment un gros gros
chantier je développe plus
un point sur la gestion de l'eau
finalement on demande aussi une
ouverture plus grande la société civile
pour l'instant si vous voulez que ce
soit dans les stages dans les comités de
bassin
les agences de l'eau comment dire il n'y
a pas suffisamment de de représentants
de la société civique et bien
représentée dans ces notamment quoi et
on demande que par exemple les
organisations syndicales puissent être
aussi membre de ces organismes que les
césaires soient ont été écartés
à chaque fois que nous menons des
auditions et qu'on demande les avis sur
la manière dont les gouvernance
organisées chaque partie prenante nous
dise on n'a pas suffisamment de place
donc mais c'est intéressant ça veut dire
que c'est peut-être le fonctionnement
même de ces organisations qu'il faut
interroger c'est à dire qu'on a des
syndicats ou des collectivités très
importantes qui peuvent parfois des
collectivités ce qu'on appelle la main
levée on n'a pas suffisamment le temps
le la capacité de porter véritablement
un avis ou de dialoguer de discuter mais
c'est un sujet c'est un vrai sujet c'est
à dire en toile de fond souvent quand ça
arrive en commission plénière les sujets
sont déjà tranchés en fait ils sont déjà
tranchés en amont c'est un point de vue
il mériterait de mais voilà globalement
mais c'est intéressant d'avoir votre
avis sur ce sujet là beaucoup de parties
prenantes
s'attachent à dire que en France ça
marche plutôt pas trop mal mais que le
système est lourd il est complexe et
qu'on a du mal à trouver sa place
c'est un petit peu ce que vous partagez
pour pas fermer la porte
aux organisations qui veulent
s'intéresser à l'eau en gros parce que
c'est un peu ce qui se passe jusqu'à
présent quoi si vous voulez donc c'est
plutôt positif ça dans la bien vu dans
de ses yeux nous l'intérêt qu'on a vu à
travers nos travaux tous les membres du
16-2 donc qui ont vraiment pris à coeur
de travailler sur notre avis ça montre
qu'il y a une volonté ça pousse ça
pousse dans bas quoi donc ça c'est
plutôt positif je pense
vous avez pas répondu sur la
planification dans les documents
d'urbanisme
donc on l'a mis dans nos c'est pour nous
c'est une évidence ça cause pas assez on
a eu quelques exemples d'une industrie
qui voulait s'installer et qui avait
besoin d'eau et là où s'installer il y
en a pas alors le document italien
tellement loin que bah du coup on arrête
on arrête pas on pourra vous donner cet
exemple là et puis également mais là
c'était sur Rennes où Rennes veut
agrandir je crois que c'était 16000
logements faut aussi savoir d'où vient
l'eau de Rennes elle vient du Centre
Bretagne donc ça veut dire que l'eau
elle vient d'un endroit on a mis un
autre donc cette solidarité on va dire
urbain rural d'autres on dit ah bon aval
c'est vraiment de très important et qui
doit se traduire dans les documents
d'aménagement dans les plus dans les
détails si on va jusqu'au plu par
exemple on a mis qu'il fallait remettre
des partout qui s'occupent de mettre des
haies c'est dans le pays c'est aussi un
boulot pour les agriculteurs mais c'est
aussi dans les villes tout ça mérite les
discussions toujours dans le même
objectif retenir l'eau par les retenir
les sols par les donc l'objectif est
bien compris maintenant comment on
orchestre ça c'est pas évident
mais moi je trouve que on sensibilise
pas suffisamment la population
aux problèmes de l'eau et on l'a
sanctionne
l'été on leur demande de pas arroser de
pas laver les voitures de pas faire
toutes sortes de choses et on n'explique
pas suffisamment à la population les
problèmes que l'on risque de rencontrer
dans un temps court
la vie qui apprécient-il notre avis sur
l'eau c'était sur la sobriété qui était
donc qui a bien montré que franchement
il fallait une prise de conscience
générale quoi c'est vrai que sur l'eau
c'est absolument nécessaire et c'est
vrai que notamment dans les zones
touristiques on s'aperçoit qu'il y a des
surcapacités d'accueil mais il y a pas
d'eau dans certaines dans certaines
villes notamment voilà et pour revenir
sur l'exemple pour les industriels par
exemple quand il y a de l'aménagement du
territoire à faire c'est vrai que la
problématique de l'eau doit être
primordiale parce qu'on s'est aperçu
notamment Alain il connaît aussi bien à
l'IFRI notre entrepreneur d'où le dieu
voulait installer une usine de
fabrication de c'était de brioche et
finalement le dossier a été très loin il
y a eu des conflits autour de
l'intention de l'usine tout ça pour
s'apercevoir en bout de course il y
avait pas d'eau donc il a dit dans les
médias il a dit si j'avais su qu'il y
avait pas d'eau mais c'était pas il
fallait chercher une autre ville quoi
une autre ville d'implantation voilà et
donc c'est donc ça prouve que dans les
le prix c'est pas encore prégnant quoi
voilà il faut absolument qu'il y ait une
prise de conscience générale et nous on
espère que notre avis apportera cette
pierre à cette l'alerte qu'on a voulu
faire et surtout la prise de conscience
générale que l'eau devait être mis au
sommet de la des agendas des politiques
publiques
chers collègues on est à quelques
minutes de notre conclusion ce qui a
éventuellement d'autres questions
Marie-Claude
tout à l'heure mais je voudrais avoir
votre avis sur
éventuellement les à la fois les les
retenues colinaires et à la fois les
grandes bassines parce que il y aura pas
d'agriculture si on n'arrose pas de
toute façon et c'est vrai que partage de
l'eau implique de la sobriété mais dans
l'agriculture on pourra pas se passer
d'eau quel est votre avis par rapport à
ça déjà ce qu'on veut dire c'est bon il
y a eu le conflits de sainte-souligne
qui est bien regrettable qu'on regagne
bien bien mais c'est que il faut savoir
qu'il y a des endroits où ça se passe
bien oui justement un consensus qui se
fait parce que tous les acteurs se
retrouvent autour d'une table arrivent à
discuter autour des ptge
par exemple souvent
nous on ne préconise dans les
préconisations on dit qu'il faut
développer les ptgu mais si vous voulez
nous on pense que on peut trouver des
solutions mais il faut absolument que
tous les acteurs puissent ne pas se
sentir exclu et où alors et où ça se
passe mal souvent c'est parce que si
vous voulez il y a
une partie de la culture qui ont dit
qu'il y avait un accaparement de la
ressource si vous voulez donc quand on
commence à parler d'accaparent ça va mal
quoi si vous voulez et pour éviter ça il
faut absolument qu'il y a un comment
dire
consensus sur le sur l'analyse de la
situation quoi en gros sur les quantités
comment qu'on va les répartir et avant
de venir là dans le taxi on a appelé un
agriculteur qui nous a dit que ça se
passait bien dans certains départements
très bien notamment on vend des après il
y a des raisons objectives aussi c'est à
dire que il nous a expliqué que les
bassines qui avaient été installés en
Vendée il y avait pas de consommation en
aval
donc c'est sa simplifie beaucoup les
choses si vous faites des bassines et
que en aval voilà il y a mais c'est très
complexe donc il faut que les
scientifiques apportent leur
contribution les agriculteurs les
sociétés environnementales et tous les
parties prenantes que si vous les élus
évidemment quoi mais nous on pense que
c'est possible mais il faut il faut
disons prendre le bon chemin pour que
que ça se passe bien
compris que dans le Cher ça a commencé
bien les discussions et puis on nous a
dit oui c'est bien le cher mais il faut
faire attention c'est un sous bassin et
puis à la fin on arrive à la Loire quoi
donc si tout le monde fait des bassines
dans tous les départements ça va être
difficile donc il faut plus la loi qui
est un débit
sauvage donc faut discuter puis il faut
discuter commencez par un bout puis des
interges interprétés
tout ça là donc là on a déjà
l'organisation commitive se fait au
niveau du comité de bassin justement
c'est là je vous parlais de de mieux
maîtriser à la fois la connaissance des
quantités et mieux maîtriser à la fois
la connaissance des usages et des
consommations et il faut partager ces
enjeux avant toute chose et puis après
une fois qu'on les partage on regarde
comment on distribue
et c'est là où il y a des choix parfois
difficiles mais c'est là on doit faire
les choix et souvent déjà ces enjeux-là
ne sont pas suffisamment partagés tout
le monde a le sentiment que l'eau est
inépuisable pour tout le monde mais
c'est pas le cas
c'est pas le cas et ça sera le moins en
moins de cas sur les quantités on s'est
intéressé sur le nombre de plan d'eau et
ben c'est en train d'être travaillé avec
mais là il faut des satellites parce que
on va aller on va pas aller mesurer tous
les plans d'eau en taille donc tout ça
ça se fait
peut-être qu'il faut que ça aille un peu
plus vite
peut-être un peu plus vite et puis
dernière il faut savoir ce qu'on fait
une fois qu'on saura qu'est-ce qu'on va
en faire est-ce que c'est un effet
rebond ce qu'on aura derrière ou en
effet de oulala oula attention ça
diminue c'est à dire il faut vraiment
travailler en différentiel et souvent
nous souvent nous répondre mais attendez
de l'eau il y en a partout c'est vrai
qu'il y en a beaucoup d'eau en France on
a de la chance c'est des différencies
c'est les recherches divers qui se font
moins bien et donc c'est vraiment sur
plusieurs années - 20 - 40 % d'ici je
crois 15 20 ans c'est ça qu'il faut
travailler de l'eau il y en a mais il y
en a pas assez à ce renouvelle pas assez
etc donc vraiment c'est un travail sur
sur de prévisions d'anticipation puis
elle est différenciée oui la manière
dont tu l'utilises et très différenciée
au niveau des bassins on arrive madame
la Présidente peut-être sur la fin si
vous voulez bien ce qui nous intéresse
aussi dans le dialogue que nous
établissons aussi avec vous c'est que en
fait une des plus grandes difficultés
c'est de trouver des voies même si elles
sont difficiles pour
essayer de voir comment on peut
travailler l'acceptabilité d'un certain
nombre de projets
et ces voilà elles sont intéressantes
vraiment à travailler et à creuser
aujourd'hui parce qu'on sait que demain
il faudra limiter autant que possible
même si on pourra pas les limiter
systématiquement les rapports de force
et les conflits donc la nature même du
CESU est intéressante aussi à ce niveau
là c'est à dire dans les réflexions
pouvaient avoir je vous laisse le soin
de de conclure pas du tout pour conclure
c'est pour tirer votre attention sur
effectivement un avis qu'on avait fait
sur l'acceptabilité des infrastructures
énergétiques l'année dernière qui était
centrée sur la question des énergies
renouvelables par exemple mais pas que
il y en avait traité justement des idées
de comment est-ce qu'on peut travailler
sur l'association et l'installation dans
les territoires de différents typologies
d'infrastructures et donc il y a
beaucoup d'idées qui peuvent être je
crois transposés aussi sur la question
de l'eau mais plus largement sur
l'ensemble des questions de ressources
naturelles en général
écoutez merci beaucoup merci messieurs
de nous avoir consacré ce temps et
donner vos informations je vous remercie
beaucoup merci mes chers collègues